a hero's welcome home for Rory McIlroy
back at the golf club where it all began
the newly crowned US Open winner Charles
Hollywood golf club in county down to
address the world's media to see the
impact that I've had on the junior
members here is incredible and you know
last week was fantastic it was
incredible you know the Gulf that I play
I've never played before my life and
hopefully I can just keep it going the
walls of the clubhouse tell the amazing
story of the local school boy who was so
good at eight years of age that the club
changed its entry rules simply to
accommodate his phenomenal talent the
ginger ginger convener at the time and
then the golf pros Eddie Harper michael
berman and those two guys really you
know spotted the potential Lemuria and
they basically said that the club look
if you don't let him in somebody else's
gonna let him because he's not good and
you know the club were have enough
foresight to understand that and reduce
the aids within minutes of arriving home
in Northern Ireland McIlroy tweeted this
picture of his latest prize sitting
proudly on the kitchen table the hope
here is that this will be the first of
many majors and golf here in Northern
Ireland is expecting to benefit as well
they show the world they've got the
talent now they want the world to come
visit and play the eight-year-old Rory
would sign his card after each round
with the wards US Open winner a
schoolboy bowls in 1997 that came
through this week and a Brady Sky News
at Hollywood golf club County Down